This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1959, after nearly a century and a half of British colonial rule, the people of Singapore took the first step toward their independence. They voted to run their own internal government. The British colonial rule was restored after the Second World War. A series of colonial administrators have ruled and ordered our lives. Well, times have changed and will still change. We the people of Singapore have decided to run the affairs of Singapore. It was a joyous moment, but they inherited a difficult situation. All of us want a better and a fuller life. joyous moment, but they inherited a difficult situation.
这里是 99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1959年，在经历了一个半世纪的英国殖民统治之后，新加坡人民迈出了走向独立的第一步。他们投票决定自己管理内部政府。二战后英国殖民统治得以恢复。一系列殖民官员统治并主宰了我们的生活。好吧，时代变了，还将继续变。我们新加坡人民决定管理新加坡的事务。这是一个欢乐的时刻，但他们接手了一个困难的局面。我们所有人都想要一个更好、更充实的生活。欢乐的时刻，但他们接手了一个困难的局面。
Singapore was bombed heavily by Japan during the Second World War, and again by the allies after Singapore fell to the Japanese. A lot of its infrastructure was in ruins, including the port, which had brought foreign goods and a multi-ethnic, multilingual population of people to the island for centuries. No port meant no jobs. Party was rampant. Most of the island's residents were living
新加坡在第二次世界大战期间遭到日本的猛烈轰炸，在新加坡沦陷给日本后又遭到盟军的轰炸。其许多基础设施沦为废墟，其中包括几个世纪以来一直为该岛带来外国货物以及多民族、多语言人口的港口。没有港口就意味着没有工作。党派竞争十分猖獗。该岛的大多数居民都生活在
in unpermitted makeshift houses crammed into crowded villages throughout the island. If you don't know, the country of Singapore is tiny. Today the entire nation is really just one city. It takes less than 45 minutes to drive across the island, with traffic. But in the 1950s, there were villages. And those villages were known as Campong's, a local Malay word. That's producer Katie Thornton.
全岛挤满拥挤村庄的违章简易房里。如果你不知道的话，新加坡这个国家非常小。如今整个国家其实只是一座城市。即使算上交通，开车穿过全岛也只需要不到45分钟。但在20世纪50年代，这里还存在着村庄。这些村庄被称为“Kampong”，这是一个当地的马来语词汇。这位是制作人凯蒂·桑顿。
She's a full bright national geographic fellow and has spent the last four months in Singapore. Campong communities were strong and close knit. But the living wasn't easy. Multiple families might share one toilet or one kitchen. Many of the Campong's relied on gas for lighting and cooking. And most houses were made of superflammable palm leaves or wood with roofs made of sheet metal.
她是富布赖特国家地理学者，在新加坡度过了过去的四个月。甘榜社区关系紧密，充满凝聚力。但生活并不容易。多个家庭可能共用一个厕所或一个厨房。许多甘榜依赖燃气进行照明和做饭。大多数房屋由极易燃烧的棕榈叶或木材制成，屋顶则是金属薄板。
The government wanted to raise the quality of life for the people. They rebuilt the port and created factory jobs. They made all the kids learn English so that Singapore could feel united under one language, but the biggest undertaking of all was to get the people out of that roof huts and into modern housing. The biggest undertaking of all was to get the people out of thatch-druf huts and into modern housing. And one of the biggest challenges would be doing it with extremely limited land space. In 1960, they formed the Housing and Development Board, or HDB.
政府希望提高人民的生活质量。他们重建了港口并创造了工厂就业机会。他们让所有的孩子学习英语，以便新加坡能在一种语言下感受到团结，但其中最大的举措是将人们从茅草屋中迁出，搬进现代化的住房。其中最大的举措是将人们从茅草屋中迁出，搬进现代化的住房。而最大的挑战之一就是在极其有限的土地空间内完成这一任务。1960年，他们成立了建屋发展局，简称HDB。
And just five years later, they had already housed 400,000 people. Well, over 400,000 people, a quarter of Singapore's population has been rehoused in the last five years in these bright modern area flats. No way out in the world, except in Russia and West Germany, is the rate of rehousing faster than in Singapore. The HDB achieved this pretty amazing feat by going vertical. When planning for a growing population, most urban planners expand their cities outward, but in land-limited Singapore, that is not an option.
仅仅五年后，他们就已经安置了40万人。嗯，超过40万人，在过去的五年里，新加坡四分之一的人口被重新安置在这些明亮现代的组屋中。世界上除了苏联和西德之外，没有任何地方的重新安置速度比新加坡更快。建屋发展局通过向高空发展，实现了这一令人惊叹的壮举。在规划不断增长的人口时，大多数城市规划者会将城市向外扩张，但在土地有限的新加坡，这不是一种选择。
Today, Singapore's tallest public housing buildings are 50 stories high, the tallest in the world. But from the very beginning, the Housing and Development Board went vertical. The people of Singapore demand high standards to their governments, and they are prepared to work hard and are capable of high skills. For them, the sky is the limit. Singapore is acquiring the one whole mark of a great civilized community, magnificent buildings, plus comparable workers housing.
今天，新加坡最高公共住宅建筑高达50层，是世界上最高的。但从一开始，建屋发展局就选择了向高空发展。新加坡人民对政府要求很高，他们准备努力工作，并具备高超的技能。对他们来说，天空才是极限。新加坡正在获得一个伟大文明社区的所有标志：宏伟的建筑，加上可比拟的工人住宅。
Today, Singapore is the third richest nation in the world, and 80% of Singaporeans still live in these tall cement HDB flats. There's about 10,000 public housing buildings on the island, and new flats are going up all the time. It's not the glitzy, futuristic, Singapore skyline you see in movies like Crazy Rich Asians. The buildings are tall and cement with housing block numbers painted boldly down the sides, helping Singaporeans locate themselves in the monotonous sea of nearly identical buildings. Throughout the 1960s and 70s, HDB public housing developments sprung up all over the country. Kuh Ehun is a historian in Singapore.
如今，新加坡是世界上第三富有的国家，80%的新加坡人仍然住在这些高层水泥建屋发展局组屋中。岛上大约有10,000栋公共住宅建筑，新的组屋一直在拔地而起。这并不是你在《疯狂亚洲富豪》等电影中看到的耀眼、具有未来感的新加坡天际线。这些建筑高大且由水泥建成，房屋编号醒目地喷涂在侧面，帮助新加坡人在近乎完全相同的建筑构成的单调海洋中辨别方向。在20世纪60年代和70年代，建屋发展局的公共住宅开发项目在全国各地如雨后春笋般涌现。许意云是新加坡的一位历史学家。
She was born in 1966 and has lived in HDB flats for most of her life. She remembers watching this housing crop up everywhere on the island. They weren't all designed exactly the same, but pretty close. A design style is different, but what doesn't change is basically everything becomes like a matchbox. So you're living in a little hole inside a concrete structure. As people moved into these drab concrete towers, a lot of them missed the vibe of their old communities, what they called the Kompong spirit. But there was a lot to like about their new homes, like having their own bathrooms and kitchens with electricity and plumbing. A place where they can have their own privacy,
她出生于1966年，大半生都住在组屋里。她还记得看着这种住房在岛上各处涌现。它们并非全部设计得一模一样，但也差不多。设计风格有所不同，但不变的是，基本上一切都变得像火柴盒一样。所以你住在一个混凝土结构里面的小洞里。随着人们搬进这些单调的混凝土大楼，许多人怀念他们旧社区的氛围，也就是他们所说的甘榜精神。但他们的新家也有很多让人喜爱的地方，比如拥有自己的浴室和厨房，通了电和管道。一个他们可以拥有自己隐私的地方，
a place where they don't get flooded every time it rains, you know. And so people moved in and the government kept building. And the building just kept getting higher over the years. But despite the privacy the architecture afforded, Ihun didn't always feel alone. As a kid growing up in HDB flats, she remembers seeing shadowy figures floating above her bed. She asked her mom about it. So when I was very young, I told my mom,
一个下雨天不会被淹的地方，你知道的。于是人们搬了进去，政府一直在建设。多年来，建筑物也越建越高。但尽管建筑提供了隐私，意云并不总觉得自己是孤单一人。作为一个在组屋里长大的孩子，她记得看到黑影在她床上方漂浮。她向母亲询问了这件事。所以当我非常小的时候，我告诉我妈妈，
I said, why is it that I see that image just above me? And then she say, Ciligol, this used to be a cemetery. Of the four apartments E-Hoon has lived in, two of them have been on old cemeteries. That might seem like bad luck. But in Singapore, where land is scarce, it's not unlikely for apartment buildings to be built on land
我说，为什么我总是看到那个影像就在我上方？然后她说，Ciligol，这里以前是个墓地。在意云住过的四套公寓中，有两套建在旧墓地上。这看起来可能有点运气不好。但在土地稀缺的新加坡，公寓楼建在不久前还是墓地的土地上并不罕见。
that was graveyard not too long ago. But building on top of a graveyard has its complications, and in one cemetery, called Peck Sandtang, the new housing development disrupted more than just the dead. It disrupted a way of life. Yeah, I'm a Juan, Juan Yu-King. Growing up in the 50s and 60s, Mr. Juan was a city boy. But his dad would bring him the eight miles from their home near Singapore's growing city center to the overgrown rainforest of Pec-Santhang cemetery,
但在墓地上建造房屋有其复杂性，在一个名为白沙山（Peck San Theng）的墓地里，新的住宅开发项目扰乱的不仅仅是死者。它打破了一种生活方式。是的，我是阮，阮育庆。在50年代和60年代长大，阮先生是一个城市男孩。但他的父亲会带他走八英里路，从他们位于新加坡日益扩大的市中心附近的家，来到长满野生热带雨林的白沙山墓地，
to pray at the graves of their family and friends. When I was a kid, I was a young boy. I was wandering around the hillsides, walking through the grass, we say prayers, we make offerings. Mr. Quan's family was Chinese, and they believed that if the dead were well taken care of, it not only meant peace for the departed, it could also bring direct benefits to the descendants. So Mr. Quan kept going as he got older. In going to the cemetery, it wasn't just a family affair. It was a community function.
去祭拜他们家人和朋友的墓地。当我还是个孩子，还是个小男孩的时候。我在山坡上闲逛，穿过草地，我们祈祷，我们供奉。阮先生的家人是华侨华人，他们认为如果死者得到妥善照顾，不仅意味着逝者安息，还能给后代带来直接的好处。所以随着年龄的增长，阮先生一直坚持去那里。去墓地不仅仅是一场家庭事务。它是一项社区活动。
Chinese migrants to Singapore set up social service organizations to help take care of their community from the cradle to the grave and beyond. Mr. Quan and his friends would wander the untamed hillsides to the graves of their long dead community members. There they'd burn incense and fake paper money, things they thought that the dead might need in the afterlife. And then they'd just hang out at the grave. So after all the prayers are said and done,
来到新加坡的中国移民建立了一系列社会服务组织，旨在照顾他们社区从生到死及至身后的一切。阮先生和他的朋友们会漫步在荒凉的山坡上，来到他们早已去世的社区成员的墓前。在那里他们会焚烧香烛和假纸钱，他们认为死者在阴间可能会需要这些东西。然后他们就会在墓地附近闲逛。所以，所有的祈祷都结束后，
we have a lovely meal of roast pork, roast duck, and so on, and it was a wonderful event. I mean, we kids look forward to that, actually. When you hear Mr. Kwan talk about going to the cemetery, you start to get why he enjoyed it. It was a nice change from the congestion and cement of the city. And it wasn't just a natural scenery that was impressive. The tombs were amazing. People would spend a fortune on big elaborate memorials with stone lions and meticulous carvings. Peck centang cemetery was sprawling
我们有一顿丰盛的饭菜，有烧肉、烧鸭等等，这是一个美妙的活动。我的意思是，我们小孩子们其实很期待那一刻。当你听到阮先生谈论去墓地的事时，你开始理解他为什么喜欢那里了。这是摆脱城市拥挤和水泥森林的一个美好改变。而且不仅仅是自然风光令人印象深刻。陵墓也非常惊人。人们会花一大笔钱建造配有石狮子和精致雕刻的大型复杂纪念碑。白沙山墓地蔓延着
with these huge ornate tombs. At least 30 meters broad, if you, there's about 33 yards, you know? 30 meters wide. A tomb like that could easily be bigger than a three bedroom HDB apartment today. And Mr. Kwan is describing just a single family grave. On top of that, Peck Sandthing had a lot of shared graves.
这些巨大的华丽坟墓。如果你去看看，至少有30米宽，大约是33码，你知道吗？30米宽。这样的墓地甚至可能比今天的三居室组屋还要大。而阮先生描述的只是一个单一的家族墓地。除此之外，白沙山还有许多合葬墓。
One big tombstone would mark a huge area where members of a professional or social group were buried together. At Peck Sandthing, there were plots for all sorts of groups. We have like the Taylor's Association, the Pock Cellars Association, the Opera's Shingles Association,
一个巨大的墓碑标志着一个巨大的区域，职业或社会团体的成员被埋葬在一起。在白沙山，有各种各样的团体墓地。我们有裁缝公会、酿酒公会、粤剧公会，
the, I mean, you name it. An ideal Chinese tomb is supposed to be on a hill so that the fortunes of the deceased can run down to future generations. In China and in the Chinese diaspora, the words hill and cemetery were pretty much used interchangeably. San of Pexanthang means hill.
那个，我的意思是，你能想到的都有。一个理想的中国墓地应该建在山上，这样逝者的福气就可以流传给后代。在中国和海外华人社群中，“山”和“墓地”这两个词几乎是可以互换使用的。“Peck San Theng”中的“San”就是山的意思。
The name translates to pavilions on the Jade Hills, a reference to the Graveyard's 12 covered structures where visitors could rest and eat after making offerings at the graves. Mr. Quan remembers these pavilions well, but that doesn't mean he knew his way around the graveyard. With all those grand tombs, the cemetery was enormous, 324 acres.
这个名字翻译过来就是“翡翠山上的凉亭”，指的是墓地里12个带顶的建筑物，访客在墓前祭拜后可以在那里休息和进食。阮先生对这些凉亭记忆犹新，但这并不意味着他对墓地了如指掌。拥有如此众多宏伟陵墓的墓地面积巨大，达到324英亩。
That's about four times the size of Disneyland. In a country half the size of LA. Sometimes the driver of the bus or the lorry bringing us there will lose his way. Then you drive around in the circle. We have to get some of the villagers to come out and guide us. When Mr. Kwan says they would get villagers to come out and guide them, he doesn't mean people from a nearby village. He means people who lived in the graveyard.
这大约是迪士尼乐园大小的四倍。在一个面积只有洛杉矶一半的国家里。有时载我们去的公交车或卡车司机会迷路。然后你就会绕着圈子开车。我们不得不让一些村民出来给我们带路。当阮先生说他们会叫村民出来带路时，他指的不是附近村庄的人，而是住在墓地里的人。
So people were kind of living among the tombstones, is that correct? Yes, yes, yes. Peck Sandthing was in, a cemetery full of life. It was a self-sufficient village that began almost a hundred years before Mr. Quon started visiting. When members of Singapore's growing Cantonese community realized they needed more space to bury their dead, they purchased land on what was then the edge of town. And as the cemetery grew, so did the village. An active graveyard meant there were jobs to be had. Graves had to be dug, tombstones carved,
所以人们有点像是住在墓碑之间，是这样吗？是的，是的，是的。白沙山是一个充满生气的墓地。这是一个自给自足的村庄，在阮先生开始造访的近一百年前就已经存在了。当新加坡不断增长的广府社群成员意识到他们需要更多空间来埋葬死者时，他们购买了当时处于城镇边缘的土地。随着墓地的扩大，村庄也随之扩大。一个活跃的墓地意味着有工作可做。必须挖墓穴、雕刻墓碑，
refreshments sold to mourners, so people built thatched roof homes right there among the graves. This actually happened in a lot of big cemeteries that sprawled across the tiny island. The living just kind of lived alongside the dead. By the 1970s, Pexan Tang Village had almost 2,000 residents. There was a large Chinese-style gate
向悼唁者出售茶点，于是人们就在坟墓中间建造了茅草屋。这实际上发生在横跨这个小岛的许多大型墓地上。活人就这样与死者比邻而居。到20世纪70年代，白沙山村已经有近2000名居民。村口有一个
at the entrance to the village. The village had its own clinic, convenient stores with thatched in 10 roofs. There was a popular coffee shop and a dim sum eatery, and an open-air movie theater where people sat under their umbrellas to watch films in the rain. Many of the residents worked at a soy sauce factory in the village.
巨大的中式牌坊。村里有自己的诊所，开着茅草和铁皮屋顶的便利店。这里有一家受欢迎的咖啡店和一家点心店，还有一个露天电影院，人们撑着伞坐在雨中看电影。许多居民在村里的一家酱油厂工作。
Livestock was reared, kids were born and families raised, all among graves. I used to hang around a coffee shop, run around, go play, play with mobiles, gamble. That's Mr. Lee. He just goes by Lee, and he grew up in Peckstanthang Village. Like kids anywhere else on the island, he climbed fruit trees and played hopscotch with his neighbors. His house was just a few houses over from the nearest gravestones.
这里饲养着家畜，孩子们出生并在这里抚养长大，这一切都发生在坟墓之中。我以前经常在咖啡店闲逛，跑来跑去，玩耍，和弹珠玩耍，赌博。那是李先生。他只叫李，在白沙山村长大。就像岛上其他地方的孩子一样，他在果树上爬来爬去，和邻居玩跳房子。他的家离最近的墓碑只有几栋房子的距离。
Lee wasn't afraid to be living so close to the dead, but he did hear ghost stories. The old people said, everyone of them said, go stay, everywhere you go. There was a shallow well at Pavilion 3, where it was rumored many people died, pulled under by what Lee calls water ghosts. A tomb at Pavilion 5 boasted two large stone lions, and villagers would always complain that they came to life after dark and ate their chickens. But to Lee and other villagers,
李并不害怕住在离死者这么近的地方，但他确实听过鬼故事。老人们说，每个人都这么说，去待着，无论你走到哪里。3号凉亭附近有一口浅井，传闻有许多人死在那里，被李所说的水鬼拉入水中。5号凉亭的一座墓穴拥有两只巨大的石狮子，村民们总是抱怨它们天黑后会活过来吃他们的鸡。但对于李和其他村民来说，
Peck's entang was home. However, life in the cemetery was about to change. As the HDB built more and more housing forcing a poor's growing population, they realized they needed more land. The Prime Minister explained that, well, we don't have enough land for the living, or the dead must keep way to the living.
白沙山就是家。然而，墓地里的生活即将改变。随着建屋发展局建造越来越多的住房来安置不断增长的贫困人口，他们意识到他们需要更多的土地。首相解释说，嗯，我们没有足够的土地留给活人，死者必须为活人让路。
In 1973, the government said there'd be no more ground burial at over 70 cemeteries, including Pec's enthing. By 1974, those who died could only be buried at the single, more sterile government-run cemetery, 16 miles from the city center. Or for a fraction of the price, they could be cremated, their ashes scattered or stored in a small urn. These were huge cultural changes, not everyone was happy. But after the war and the nation's independence, a lot of Singaporeans were willing to make
1973年，政府宣布包括白沙山在内的70多个墓地将不再进行土葬。到1974年，去世的人只能被安葬在距离市中心16英里处唯一一个更加冷清的由政府运营的墓地里。或者以极低的价格进行火化，骨灰被撒掉或存放在一个小骨灰盒里。这些都是巨大的文化变革，并不是所有人都感到高兴。但在战争和国家独立之后，许多新加坡人愿意为了国家的经济发展做出
sacrifices for the country's development. They acknowledged that burying people in big graves just wasn't sustainable on a tiny island. Also, they kind of had to go along with the changes. Singapore has really limited freedom of speech, so when the government tells you to do something, you don't have much choice. In 1978, it happened.
牺牲。他们承认，在一个小岛上把人埋在大墓里根本不可持续。此外，他们某种程度上也必须顺应这些变化。新加坡的言论自由非常有限，所以当政府叫你做什么时，你没有太多选择。1978年，事情发生了。
The Pecsanthang Cemetery Association received a letter from the government saying a new, high-rise public housing development was going to be built on the cemetery. Their land was being reclaimed. Now remember, there are basically two groups of people at Peckson thing, the dead and the living. And both were told they had four years to clear out. The people living in Peckson thing
白沙山墓地联合会收到政府的一项信函，称将在该墓地上建造一个新的高层公共住宅开发项目。他们的土地正在被收回。现在请记住，白沙山基本上有两类人：死者和生者。两都被告知他们有四年的时间搬迁。住在白沙山的人
were mostly relocated into new government housing nearby. But it took a while. A lot of the villagers weren't happy to leave, and they stayed as long as they possibly could. Sometimes years passed the deadline, the government gave them to move. As for the dead and the association of family members who represented them, they weren't eager to move either. The association wanted to find a way to keep a piece of their land.
大多被重新安置到附近的新政府住房中。但这花了一些时间。许多村民很不情愿离开，他们尽可能长时间地留了下来。有时甚至超过了政府规定的搬迁期限几年。至于死者以及代表他们的家属协会，他们同样不急于搬迁。协会想要找到一种方法，保留他们的一块土地。
But no, the law was pretty strict. No more land burial means no more land burial. So that was that. So they hired a lawyer and pleaded with the government to let them keep just 30 acres of their original 324, enough to have a temple and some administrative buildings and to cremate the dead and build a columnbarium, a building made to hold earns. That all of a sudden one fine day we received a letter. We wanted 30 acres and they wrote back to us and said, oh, we can only spare you 8 acres. So the committee met and decided 8 acres better than no acres.
但不行，法律相当严格。不再允许土葬意味着不再允许土葬。事情就是这样。于是他们聘请了律师，恳求政府让他们保留原先324英亩土地中的30英亩，这足以建一座寺庙和一些行政建筑，并火化死者以及建造一座灵骨塔（即用来存放骨灰盒的建筑）。就在某个晴朗的日子里，我们突然收到了一封信。我们想要30英亩，他们回信说，哦，我们只能腾出8英亩给你们。于是委员会开会决定，8英亩总比没有好。
8 acres was more than most cemeteries got. At least there would be room for a columbarium and a couple of other buildings. Still, a hundred thousand bodies would have to be dug up from the cemetery. It was a huge daunting task. We put advertisements in the newspaper, telling owners of common clear-out, so to speak. I mean, I hate to use a word,
8英亩比大多数墓地得到的要多。至少还会有空间建造一座灵骨塔和其他几栋建筑。尽管如此，仍必须从墓地中挖出十万具遗体。这是一个巨大而艰巨的任务。我们在报纸上登了广告，告诉业主们要清理干净，可以说是这样。我的意思是，我讨厌用这个词，
but basically, they have to assume that swear. I might do use of it, but basically, they have to exume their grace. They wrote letters to the families, asking them to remove their dead loved ones from what was about to be a construction site. But as the deadline approached, only about half of Peck's sand things, 100,000 graves, had been unearthed. The association members were at a loss as to what to do with nearly 50,000 bodies still in the ground.
但基本上，他们必须承担……我可能会用这个词，但基本上，他们必须迁出他们的坟墓。他们写信给家属，要求他们将死去的亲人从即将成为建筑工地的地点移走。但随着截止日期的临近，白沙山的十万座坟墓中只有大约一半被发掘出来。对于地下仍然躺着的近五万具遗体，协会成员一时间不知该如何是好。
Who would pay to dig up the graves, cremate the bodies, and give them another resting place? The association explained their predicament to the housing and development board, who agreed to help them deal with the lingering dead, which is a fadding off the road. They told me 324 acres of our land. You see? The HDB and the Cemetery Association hired people from the village to dig up the bodies. People like Mr. Lee, the guy who grew up in the village at Peckson thing. Lee's mom, dad, and brother all dug up graves.
谁来支付挖掘坟墓、火化遗体以及为他们提供另一个安息之所的费用呢？协会向建屋发展局解释了他们的困境，建屋发展局同意协助他们处理这些滞留的死者，这就是开辟道路。他们告诉我要我们324英亩的土地。你瞧？建屋发展局和墓地协会雇佣了村里的人来挖掘遗体。像李先生这样在白沙山村长大的年轻人。李的妈妈、爸爸和兄弟都参与了挖墓。
Lee would walk behind them carrying their spades and tools. He studied how they removed the heavy soil from the grave and carefully broke the coffin lid. Then he was ready to do it himself. The bones have sunken into the earth and you have to scrape, scrape, scrape with the spades to find the bones. Sometimes when the work is easy,
李会跟在他们身后，拿着他们的铲子和工具。他研究他们如何从坟墓中清除厚重的泥土，并小心翼翼地撬开棺材盖。然后他准备自己动手了。骨头已经陷入泥土中，你必须用铲子刮、刮、刮才能找到骨头。有时当工作容易时，
we may spend about an hour working on a tomb. When it is a hard job, you may take us three to four hours. At first, Lee was scared to dig. Any of the bodies were only just starting to decompose. This disease of guilty job, I'm not ashamed to say it. 73 criteria to be in this job. First, you have to have the guts, second, the strength, and third, the skill. So if you have no guts, there's no way you can do this job.
我们可能花大约一个小时处理一个坟墓。当这是一项艰难的工作时，可能需要我们三到四个小时。起初，李很害怕挖掘。许多遗体才刚刚开始分解。这是一份令人感到内疚的工作，我不羞于承认这一点。要做这份工作有三个标准。首先，你必须有胆量；第二，体力；第三，技能。所以如果你没有胆量，你绝对无法胜任这项工作。
After going to work on the hill day in and day out, he got the guts. Lucy, those are things I can't even open it. When you are on the hill alone, it's futile to be frightened. You need to fulfill your application. Even if I'm frightened and alone, I still need to complete the job. And he did. After years of digging, the 100,000 bodies were all removed. The half that were unclaimed were cremated together and scattered at sea in a solemn ceremony. Like many other living members of Pexanthang, Lee and his family were re-housed in a nearby
在山上日复一日地工作后，他练就了胆量。露西，有些东西我甚至无法打开它。当你独自一人在山上时，害怕是徒劳的。你需要完成你的工作。即使我害怕且孤单，我仍然需要完成这项工作。他也确实做到了。经过多年的挖掘，十万具遗体全部被迁走。其中一半无人认领的遗体被集中火化，并在一次庄严的仪式中撒入大海。就像白沙山的许多其他在世居民一样，李和他的家人被重新安置在附近的
HDBS state. For most of the villagers, the transition wasn't easy. Sure their housing was taken care of, but you couldn't have a farm in a high rise or a tombstone carving business without burial. Lee was lucky. He found work digging up other nearby cemeteries that were also getting repossessed. Peck's sand thing had been able to hold on to eight acres. It was more than most people got, but wasn't much. Going from a 324-acre cemetery to an 8-acre complex, with
建屋发展局组屋中。对于大多数村民来说，这种过渡并不容易。当然他们的住房有着落了，但你无法在高层住宅里经营农场，也无法在没有土葬的情况下经营墓碑雕刻生意。李很幸运。他找到了工作，去挖掘其他同样面临被收回的附近墓地。白沙山得以保留了八英亩土地。这比大多数人得到的要多，但并不算多。从一个324英亩的墓地缩减到一个8英亩的综合体，里面有
a temple, an administration building, and a columbarium for urns, meant space had to be maximized. There was also the issue of design aesthetics. For most Chinese, the tradition was to bury in grand tombs like the ones at Pexanthang. When it came to building the columbarium to house the urns, there was no real model to harken back to. Columbariums were novel structures because the whole practice of cremation was pretty new to a lot of Chinese Singaporeans. Just 20 years earlier, only 10% of the country's Chinese population was cremated. But by the time Pexanthang wanted to build their Columbarium, that number was almost 70%.
一座寺庙、一栋行政大楼和一个存放骨灰盒的灵骨塔，这意味着空间必须被最大化利用。此外还有设计美学的问题。对于大多数华人来说，传统是将死者安葬在白沙山那样宏伟的陵墓中。在建造用来安放骨灰盒的灵骨塔时，并没有真正可以借鉴的模范。灵骨塔是新颖的结构，因为火化整套实践对许多新加坡华人来说相当陌生。就在20世纪20年代之前，该国华人人口中只有10%选择火化。但到了白沙山想要建造他们的灵骨塔时，这个数字已经接近70%。
Without much by way of architectural precedent for the columbarium, the Pexanthang Association took a gamble. They chose a somewhat controversial architect who cut his teeth designing brutalist superstructures, a modernist named Tay Kang soon. That project was an interesting moment for me because I've been thinking about the problem of how do you modernize and yet respect the traditions and the history and the aesthetics of the past. Mr. Tai didn't want to build a warehouse for the dead. That, he said, would be antithetical to the quote, nature loving and Feng Shui oriented ethos of Chinese burial. But there is a problem of how to accommodate the number of urns that had to be entered within the Columbia.
由于缺乏灵骨塔的建筑先例，白沙山协会决定冒险一试。他们选择了一位颇具争议的建筑师，他曾设计过粗野主义超大型建筑，这位现代主义者名叫戴康顺。那个项目对我来说是一个有趣的时刻，因为我一直在思考这样一个问题：如何在实现现代化的同时，又尊重过去的传统、历史和美学。戴先生不想为死者建造一个仓库。他说，这与中国传统葬礼所奉行的“热爱自然”和“风水导向”的精神背道而驰。但这里存在一个问题，即如何容纳必须安葬在灵骨塔内的骨灰盒数量。
And so just like the housing and development board did when faced with the issue of overcrowding, Mr. Ta built up. From the outside, it almost looked like any other new multi-story construction for the living. Before the Colomberium opened in 1986, one newspaper said it could easily be mistaken for a flashy new condominium, but the inside was different. Mr. Tays' Colomberium stretches up over about nine different staggered levels. The building rises gently,
因此，就像建屋发展局在面对过度拥挤问题时所做的那样，戴先生选择了向上建造。从外表上看，它几乎就像任何其他为活人建造的新多层建筑。在灵骨塔于1986年开放之前，一家报纸曾报道说，它很容易被误认为是一个华丽的新公寓大楼，但内部却截然不同。戴先生设计的灵骨塔向上延伸，跨越大约九个不同的交错层级。建筑缓缓上升，
in a series of cascading stories and half-stories, forming cement hills, like traditional Chinese tombs. The large windows and skylit corridors made it sunny and airy. Earns line the walls, from floor to ceiling. There was a waiting list of over 20,000 earns from the cemetery ready to move into Pexantang, Colombarium. But nearby housing units for the living weren't so quick to get sold. As promised, those HDB flats were going up all over the grounds that were filled with that body just a couple years earlier.
通过一系列错落有致的楼层和半层，形成了如同传统中式陵墓一般的混凝土山丘。巨大的窗户和天窗走廊使其充满阳光和微风。骨灰盒从地面一直排列到天花板。有超过20,000个来自墓地的骨灰盒在候补名单上，准备搬入白沙山灵骨塔。但附近活人住的住宅单元却没那么快售出。正如承诺的那样，那些建屋发展局组屋正在几年前还挤满尸体的土地上拔地而起。
They called the development Bishon, a Mandarin version of the Cantonese pecsan, or Jade Hills. The new Bishon development had everything the HDB imagined people needed. They opened a train stop, what Singapore calls, mass rapid transit or MRT. There were schools, malls, entertainment, and easy access to the city. In other words, it was an ideal place to live, except for one thing. The Ghosts. Newspapers wrote about ghost sightings in Bishan. The new MRT station there was known to be haunted by ghosts from the cemetery.
他们将这个开发项目命名为碧山（Bishan），这是粤语“碧山”（意为翡翠山）的普通话版本。新的碧山开发项目拥有建屋发展局设想人们需要的一切。他们开通了一个火车站，也就是新加坡人所说的大众捷运或MRT。这里有学校、商场、娱乐设施，并且交通便利，能够轻松前往市区。换句话说，这是一个理想的居住地方，除了有一件事。鬼魂。报纸上报道了在碧山看到的鬼魂。那里的新地铁站众所周知闹鬼，闹的是来自墓地的鬼魂。
Like, apparently it was just common knowledge. Do you hear any stories? Yes, yes, yes. It was well known throughout the whole of the Bishan MRT station. Everybody tried to avoid getting off, they say, especially the last train at night. There were reports of a ghostly woman who boarded the last night train at Visan, and without fanfare, took off her head and put it on the seat next to her.
就像，这显然是一个常识。你听到过什么故事吗？是的，是的，是的。整个碧山地铁站对此都非常清楚。每个人都尽量避免下车，他们说，尤其是晚上的最后一班车。有报道称，一个女鬼在碧山登上了最后一班夜行列车，若无其事地摘下自己的头，放在身旁的座位上。
Some passengers were known to cast no reflection on the train windows. Many of the residents who did move in didn't want any additional reminders of their neighborhoods Macomb history. But one tangible piece of evidence remained. One of the cemetery's covered pavilions still stood near the new train station. Until the Peck-Santhing Association got a call from the Housing and Development Board about shadows. They say that the residents have been complaining that they see shadows and light around that
众所周知，一些乘客在列车车窗上照不出倒影。许多搬进来的居民不想再有任何关于他们社区恐怖历史的额外提醒。但留下了一个有形的证据。墓地的一座带顶凉亭仍然矗立在新火车站附近。直到白沙山协会接到建屋发展局关于阴影的电话。他们说居民一直在抱怨他们在那个凉亭周围看到了阴影和光线——
pavilion creepy ghostly shadows. What shadows are they talking about? I would like to stay one line there and see what are the shadows that come here. I mean, really, we were prepared to go there and bring a cup of coffee and stay one line there. I'm happy to meet these shadows. The HDB told them the pavilion would be demolished. The association knew they had no say. The government already owned the land.
令人毛骨悚然的幽灵般的阴影。他们在谈论什么阴影？我想去那里待上一天，看看究竟是什么阴影来到这里。我的意思是，真的，我们准备去那里，带上一杯咖啡，在那儿待上一天。我很高兴能见到这些阴影。建屋发展局告诉他们，凉亭将被拆除。协会知道他们没有发言权。政府已经拥有了这片土地。
They had to oblige, even if some of them weren't happy. They demolished it. To us in Picsanti was a setting. The last remaining structure of Pandia to be demolished. And with that, all the physical remnants from the graveyard were gone from the landscape. The cemetery was no longer a cemetery. It was a huge urban development, with a multi-story columnbarium that people could easily avoid if they wanted to. And people forgot, with time, Bishan became an appealing place to live.
即使他们中的一些人并不高兴，也必须服从。他们把它拆除了。对我们白沙山人来说，这是一个打击。最后剩下的牌坊结构将被拆除。随着这一幕的发生，墓地所有的实体遗迹都从风景中消失了。这个墓地不再是一个墓地。它变成了一个巨大的城市开发项目，里面有一座多层灵骨塔，人们如果愿意的话可以轻易避开它。随着时间的推移，人们忘记了，碧山成了一个很有吸引力的居住地。
Every Chinese are very pragmatic people. I think the economic demands overrised the spiritual demands. So to speak, I'm really less for that way. People just forget that this was a symmetry before. In fact, many of the younger generation didn't know of big something symmetry. Really, it was a still living on symmetry land. Many, many other Singaporeans live on old cemeteries, whether they know it or not. So many other cemeteries were cleared for development, and it's still going on right now.
所有的中国人都非常务实。我认为经济需求压倒了精神需求。可以这么说，我在很大程度上不再坚持那种方式。人们只是忘记了这里以前是个墓地。事实上，许多年轻一代并不知道白沙山墓地。真的，它是一片仍然建在墓地土地上的土地。许多许多其他新加坡人无论是否知情，都住在旧墓地上。如此多的其他墓地为了开发而被清理，而且目前这种事情仍在继续。
Losing the cemeteries has forced a total 180 and how a lot of Singaporeans think about dying. When the first government crematorium opened in the early 60s, they did about four cremations a week. Now, more than 80% of Singaporeans get cremated when they die. Substantially more than in the US, where that number is just over 50%. And all of those traditions that people like Mr. Quanted, like burning offerings and having a feast at the grave, they've had to be way downsized to fit into the tight hallways of the Colombarians. Today Singapore has four government-run Colombariums, but Colombariums also don't meet everyone's needs because they only house cremated remains. Chinese are the ethnic majority in Singapore,
失去墓地迫使许多新加坡人对死亡的看法发生了180度的彻底转变。当第一家政府火葬场在60年代初开放时，他们每周大约进行四次火化。现在，超过80%的新加坡人在去世时选择火化。这大大高于美国，在那儿这个数字刚刚超过50%。而阮先生喜爱的那所有传统，比如烧纸祭祀和在墓前大吃一顿，为了适应灵骨塔狭窄的走廊，不得不大幅缩减规模。如今新加坡拥有四个政府运营的灵骨塔，但灵骨塔也无法满足所有人的需求，因为它们只容纳火化后的遗骸。华人在新加坡是绝对多数，
cremated remains. Chinese are the ethnic majority in Singapore, 75% of the population, and that country's Hindu community has long practiced cremation. But most of the country's large Malay community practices Islam, which doesn't permit cremation. So in 2007, the Singapore government implemented their new crypt burial system. It's a prefabricated series of interlocking concrete walls, like a deathly grid, assembled above ground, and then sunk into the earth. But you only get 15 years in your own grave, and then you have to be consolidated up to 16 bodies per grave. All this rearranging of the dead has been a painful change for a lot of Singaporeans. But there was also a widespread understanding that something had to give in order to get so many people their own homes on such a tiny island.
占人口的75%，而且该国的印度教社群长期以来一直实行火化。但该国庞大的马来社群大多信奉伊斯兰教，伊斯兰教不允许火化。因此，在2007年，新加坡政府实施了他们的新地穴土葬系统。这是一系列预制的互锁混凝土墙，就像一个死亡网格，在地面上组装，然后沉入地下。但你只能在自己的坟墓里待15年，之后你必须被合葬，每个坟墓最多可以容纳16具遗体。对许多新加坡人来说，所有这些对死者的重新安排都是一个痛苦的改变。但人们也普遍理解，为了让这么多人在这块极小的岛屿上拥有自己的家，必须有所牺牲。
And let us be practical. I mean, symmetry do take a huge land space and then land space in my opinion must be sacrificed. And the Singaporean people did sacrifice, not just the land, but centuries of rituals and traditions for their dead, all to get homes for the living. This cultural shift happened without a lot of resistance from the Singaporean people, but that is changing. I will talk to Katie Thornton about that after the break. So I'm in the studio with Katie Thornton and I want to follow up on what things are like in Singapore today. Now that almost everyone has some form of housing, whether it be public or private.
让我们务实一点。我的意思是，墓地确实占用了巨大的土地空间，在我看来，土地空间必须被牺牲。新加坡人民确实作出了牺牲，不仅牺牲了土地，还牺牲了为了死者而传承了几个世纪的仪式和传统，这一切都是为了给活人换取家园。这种文化转变并没有受到新加坡人民太多的抵制，但这种情况正在改变。稍事休息后，我将与凯蒂·桑顿谈谈这个问题。我现在和凯蒂·桑顿一起在录音室里，我想跟进一下今天新加坡的情况。现在几乎每个人都有某种形式的住房，无论是公共的还是私人的。
Today there's a lot of infrastructure for the living, and there are only a few historic cemeteries left in the entire country, and all of them are slated to be developed. Oh, okay. So, like, it's still... They're still trying to take as much of that land as possible. Yeah, totally. So, like, there's one other cemetery that has actually been getting a lot of attention lately. It's called Bukit Brown Brown and it's another Chinese cemetery.
如今，这里有很多为活人准备的基础设施，整个国家只剩下几个历史悠久的墓地，而且所有这些墓地都计划被开发。哦，好的。所以，就像，它依然……他们仍然在试图夺取尽可能多的土地。是的，完全是这样。所以，还有一个墓地最近确实受到了很多关注。它叫 Bukit Brown（咖啡山/武吉布朗），这是另一个华人墓地。
A lot of prominent early Chinese Singaporean business people and philanthropists are buried at Bukit Brown. There are a ton of those big ornate tombstones like the one Mr. Kwan described in Peck's sent thing at this site. And what are they going to do about those? Well, in 2011, the government announced that they're going to expand a highway right through the cemetery. And that highway opened earlier this year. They had to remove 4,000 graves and a lot of the tombstones were thrown away.
许多杰出的早期新加坡华人商人和慈善家都安葬在武吉布朗。这个地方有大量阮先生在白沙山描述过的那种大型华丽墓碑。那他们打算怎么处理这些墓碑呢？嗯，2011年，政府宣布他们将穿过墓地扩建一条高速公路。那条高速公路于今年早些时候开通。他们不得不移走4,000座坟墓，许多墓碑被扔掉了。
And just like at Peck's Scenting, the government said that they had to come and clear out the graves or the remains would be scattered at sea. But people actually got pretty upset. Like at this point, this is one of the only remaining cemeteries in the entire country. A bunch of volunteer historians that are advocating for the preservation of the site. They're leading tours, some academics got involved
就像在白沙山一样，政府说他们必须来清理坟墓，否则遗骸将被撒入大海。但人们实际上相当沮丧。就像在这个阶段，这是整个国家仅存的几个墓地之一。一群志愿历史学家正在倡导保护这个地方。他们带领参观，一些学者也参与进来并记录这个空间。这真的触动了人们，比如，罗曼，你还记得意云吗？是的，就是那个在节目里当过历史学家的人，但她小时候见过鬼。
and documenting the space. And it really spoke to people like, Roman, do you remember E-Hoon? Yes, she was the person that was in the piece that was a historian, but she saw ghosts when she was a kid. Yeah, totally, which she just mentioned very casually. But she actually wasn't a historian when the highway was announced.
是的，完全是，她非常随意地提到了这一点。但当高速公路宣布修建时，她其实并不是历史学家。她当时有一份工作，在一家剧院公司工作，经常四处旅行。有时在旅行时，她会去参观大型的、著名的目的地类型的墓地。当公路宣布修建时，她心想：“嘿，我从来没有去过武吉布朗。也许我该去看看。”我的意思是，它就在我自己的后院。然后她去了，就像剧情急转直下一样。她彻底改变了自己的职业生涯。为什么这会是真正让她想要改变一切的事情？她为什么这么在意？
She had this job at the time, she was working for a theater company and she was doing a lot of traveling around. And sometimes when she was traveling, she'd go and visit big, like famous destination, type of cemeteries. And when when she was traveling, she'd go and visit big, like famous destination, type of cemeteries. And when the road was announced, she was like, Hey, I've never been to Boogit Brown. Maybe I'll check it out. I mean, it's my own backyard. And then she went and it was like cut, scene change. She totally changed her career. And why was this the thing that really
由于某种原因，她就是无法接受那些从未打算被火化并扔进大海的人最终可能会落得那种下场。所以她只是想让家属们知道，如果他们有祖先安葬在武吉布朗，因为很多人已经失去了联系。没错。所以她辞去了工作，把所有这些家谱整理出来，然后她会冷不防地打电话给后代，告诉他们比如他们曾祖母的坟墓将被挖开。没错。
made her want to change everything? What does she care so much? For some reason, it just didn't really sit well with her that people who never planned on being cremated and thrown into the sea might end up there. So she just wanted families to know if they had ancestors buried at Bukit Brown, because a lot of people had lost track. Right. So she quit her job and she put together all these family trees and then she'd cold call the descendants and tell them that a grave of, say, their great grandmother was going to be dug up. Right.
有些坟墓她非常确定能找到后代，她会跟政府沟通并说：“请等等，先别挖这座坟。我能找到家属。”然后她真的找到了，并且会与他们保持联系，在整个过程中帮助他们。当家属们把遗体挖出来并转移到别处时，她会陪伴在他们身旁。
And there were graves where she was like so sure that you could find the descendants that she would talk to the government and be like, please wait, wait, like don't dig up this tomb yet. I can find the family. And then she would, and she'd stay in touch with them and help them throughout the whole process. She'd stand alongside the families as they dug the bodies up and move them elsewhere.
她现在还在这样做。即使在今年早些时候公路开通后，她仍在努力记录这个空间。为了做这项工作，她靠着积蓄生活了八年，因为她担心墓地的其余部分会被开发，所有的历史都会消失。但她确实认为，曾经可能有一段时间，为了满足活人的需求而开发这些空间是有道理的。但现在的时代有点不同了。比如我问她，我问了意云关于白沙山的事，我会放一小段她所说的话给你们听。
And she's still doing it. Even after the road opened earlier this year, she's still working to document the space. She's been living off her savings for eight years to do the work because she's worried that off her savings for eight years to do the work because she's worried that the rest of the cemetery is going to be developed and all of the history will be lost. But she does think that there was a time where maybe it made sense to develop
是的，在那个时候，在那个时候，绝对地，我的意思是，你会选择建造高层建筑来安置人民，而不是留着墓地给死者。是的，所以在那个时期，她绝对将其视为一种交换，一种生者与死者之间的直接交换。
over these spaces to get living people's needs met. But the times are a little bit different now. Like I asked her, I asked Ihuun about Peck's Santeng, and I'll play you a little bit of tape about what she said. Yeah, at that point, at that point, definitely, I mean, you would go for having high-rise building to house the people rather than to have symmetry for the dead. Yeah, so like at that time, she definitely saw it as an exchange, a director's change between the living and the dead.
为了满足生者的需求而占用这些空间。但现在的时代有些不同了。就像我问她的那样，我问了伊胡恩关于佩克山神庙的事，我放一小段录音给你们听听她是怎么说的。是的，在那个时候，在那个时候，绝对是这样的，我的意思是，你会选择建造高层建筑来安置活人，而不是为死者保留对称性。是的，所以在那个时候，她绝对认为这是一场交易，是生者与死者之间的一种董事会式的改变。
But she feels like times are kind of different now, like it might be possible to preserve some of the few old spaces on the island. So again, like this is what she said about that. There was a need for it before. Is there still that need now? You know, so it's like, if this is gone and erased, it is not replaceable and irreversible. We are talking about retaining a part of our heritage. Did your opinion about the role of cemeteries in life change. I think that cemeteries are these interesting and complicated historic sites. They're kind of an opportunity for people to inscribe their history onto the landscape. They're certainly like rife with exclusions as well. People have been excluded from cemetery spaces based on their race, based on their religion,
但她觉得现在的时代似乎有所不同了，也许有可能保留岛上仅存的一些老地方。所以再说一次，这是她对此的看法：过去对此有需求。现在还有这种需求吗？你知道的，所以这就好像，如果这些东西消失并被抹去，那是不可替代且不可逆转的。我们在谈论的是保留我们的一部分遗产。你对墓地在生活中的作用的看法改变了吗？我认为墓地是这些有趣且复杂的历史遗址。它们可以说是人们将自己的历史铭刻在土地上的一种机会。它们当然也充满了排他性。人们曾因种族、宗教、
based on their class and their inability to access like a large tombstone. But I think they also present kind of an interesting opportunity to complicate history because they're kind of more accessible archives than a lot of our historic archives. 99% Invisible was produced so sweet by Katie Thornton and edited by Katie Mingle. Two Katie's.
阶层以及无力购买大型墓碑而被排除在墓地空间之外。但我认为它们也提供了一个有趣的契机，使历史变得更加复杂，因为与我们的许多历史档案馆相比，它们是更易接近的档案馆。《99% Invisible》由 Katie Thornton 制作，Katie Mingle 编辑。两个凯蒂。
Mixing tech production by Shereef Yusuf Music by Sean Rial. Kurt Colfsted is the digital director of the rest of the team is senior editor to Laney Hall, Avery Trouffman, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. Katie Thornton is a full-bright national geographic, digital storytelling fellow who makes audio and writing about how and where we remember the dead in our changing world. Her project is called Death in the Digital Age and you can find it online at itscadythornton.com or on Instagram at itscadythornton. All this week on Instagram,
混音制作由 Shereef Yusuf 负责，音乐由 Sean Rial 创作。Kurt Colfsted 是数字总监，团队其他成员包括高级编辑 Delaney Hall、Avery Truffman、Vivian Lee、Sophia Klatsker、Emmett Fitzgerald、Joe Rosenberg 以及我，Roman Mars。Katie Thornton 是一位富布赖特国家地理数字故事讲授学者，她从事音频和写作创作，关注在我们不断变化的世界中，我们如何以及在哪里纪念逝者。她的项目名为“数字时代的死亡”，你可以在她的网站 itscadythornton.com 或 Instagram 账号 @itscadythornton 上找到她。本周在 Instagram 上，
she'll be posting some images from in and around Pexanthang and sharing stories from Singapore's changing memorial landscape. Voice over by Mike Goe from Ageless Theatre, special thanks to Koo-Ee Hoon for historical guidance. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent
她将发布一些拍摄于碧山（Pexanthang）内外的图片，并分享有关新加坡不断变化的纪念景观的故事。旁白由 Ageless Theatre 的 Mike Goe 担任，特别感谢 Koo-Ee Hoon 提供历史指导。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心电台街（Radio Row）。《99% invisible》是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个充满独立精神的
collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show in join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. But we have a calm burial full of design stories, both audio and visual at 99PI.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
播客集合，汇聚了整个播客界最具创新性的节目。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解所有节目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我（Roman Mars）以及节目（@99PI org）。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。但我们在 99PI.org 上有一个包含设计故事（包括音频和视觉）的完整墓地。Radiotopia，来自 PRX。来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。